in Hong Kong weeks of anti-government
protests took yet another violent turn
when a teenage boy was shot as protests
raged into the night mass transit
service in the city of Hong Kong has
been suspended after protesters that
fires a train station entrances and
smashed ticketing facilities the latest
demonstrations come after a ban on face
masks at all public events took effect
rainy Inocencio reports from Hong Kong
Hong Kong was on eerie lockdown Saturday
with shopping malls like this one filled
with luxury stories right behind me
clothes and the entire subway system
shut down the government also said that
if the public didn't condemn the
violence then they're stoking it early
Saturday morning Hong Kong police
exercised their new emergency powers
with arrests after this night of fury
these riot police are now loading
someone they arrested into this van at
midnight thousands remained on the
streets many stranded after the city's
expansive metro system was completely
shut down this is just some of the
destruction at this metro station the
glass has all been smashed in in fact
this is the first time that every single
metro station in Hong Kong has been
closed because of protests in the
suburbs protesters attacked a plain
clothed police officer with petrol bombs
while a teenage boy was injured by
gunfire
the second teenager shot in just three
days demonstrators directed their anger
towards Beijing targeting Chinese owned
businesses and burning a banner
celebrating China's 70th anniversary the
protests at first peaceful began almost
immediately after Carrie Lam Hong Kong's
chief executive announced a ban on
wearing masks and future rallies under
newly enacted and controversial
emergency powers this move can be
perceived as a step closer to
authoritarianism like in mainland China
your reaction this is a responsible Act
to deal with an extremely difficult
situation but many in Hong Kong do feel
their liberties are being
protesters are now calling on all
Hongkongers to wear masks every single
day moving ahead flaunting that van in
fact the next two days two more protests
are planned for CBS this morning
Saturday rainy Inocencio Hong Kong